Peggy 18
Paul France is ill and our city is a
wound inflamed by all efforts to heal
her a king once ruled headstrong and
corrupt now headless and a corpse
murdered by men just as vile
today fanatics from all sides spill
blood on every corner
a thousand terrors I mean to cure day by
day street by street Templar by Templar
hello my name is Alex Amancio and I'm
the creative director of Assassin's
Creed unity
welcome to the streets of Paris the most
beautiful city in the world in the
throes of a bloody revolution that
topped the note for them our hero Arno
surveys the scene let's make our way
down using controlled descent one of the
new additions to navigation and ACU we
have completely overhauled navigation
allowing you to plan and execute exactly
where you want to go essentially you
don't have to look for a haystack to get
the street level anymore this massive
crowd is gathered in front of McFadden
because clergy is being dragged out
players can choose whether they want to
get involved or not save the clergy
which will attract attention or let them
be murdered and stay hidden the choice
is yours
I think the gods meaning of these words
we're targeting
as you can see the city is completely
alive with inhabitants going about their
business getting robbed or investigating
curious events you will need to learn
how to read the crowd in order to get a
read on possible gameplay activities for
example the crowd looking inside the
building is curious about a recent
murder this is a cue for one of our
murder mystery missions let's take a
look inside the building seamlessly for
the first time ever pair up I will
return to see justice done we'll add
this mission to our quest log and keep
moving towards our target remember Paris
is in the midst of a revolution and
systemic fights can break out at any
moment
as you can see the people are taking the
fight to the oppressors an enemy faction
in ACU here's this one if I'm not too
late
I'll catch captains have you at his
dinner our target is in a social club
one of the new types of locations in ACU
we'll need to make our way inside let's
use a direct approach combat is much
more challenging you may see you and
players will have to make good use of
their wit tools and new combat moves
among these you will see the parry dodge
tackle and heavy attack before entering
the building let's use eagle pulse to
plan our approach and see what's waiting
for us inside
you can enter many buildings in Paris
which makes for countless new gameplay
situations let's switch the stealth mode
and try a non-lethal approach wait for
the first time in Assassin's Creed we
have a dedicated stealth mode trigger at
the press of a button
stealth mode makes you harder to detect
and allows you to circumnavigate enemies
by using a cover to cover approach our
target is hiding away on the third floor
let's get to him
it wasn't me
I'm not the man where is he
but is this the executions good you
should leave this place
it seems our target isn't here let's
make our way to the pile addresses and
track him down you can see the unique
skyline of Paris as well as the
one-to-one scale of the city which gives
navigation a completely new feeling to
support the assassin advantage on
rooftops we've added the high ground
feature letting us quickly and
seamlessly see the gameplay
opportunities around us
taverns are social hubs of a kind
offering a variety of options to players
such as shopkeepers and join in progress
opportunities for coefficients food was
becoming scarce at the stage of the
revolution and these people are arguing
over grain we could get involved but
we'll go past it for today this street
is blocked by aggressors the enemy
faction we can't fight them because that
will attract protectors and we aren't
quite strong enough to fight the module
will avoid these for now I've parkouring
up this wall
this massive crowd has gathered to watch
the public executions by the guillotine
down the street to find our target will
use eagle pulse a limited skill right
now as we haven't unlocked the full
power yet
our target captain said he is making his
way to the guillotine stand to start the
executions as an assassin
we are the blade in the crowd we have a
lot of ways we could kill our target we
can use the phantom plate then you
assassins signature weapon we could use
a stun ball on the guards or we could
use the new disguise skill and walk
right up to him in this case let's send
a message to the Templars and make this
execution as public as we can
you